(upbeat music)
♪ Yeah, okay it's Tea with Gary Vee ♪
♪ Sippin' it for free ♪
♪ I know patience is the key ♪
♪ Puttin' out all of my shit for free ♪
♪ This is Tea with Gary Vee ♪
♪ Might go make a flip ♪
- Good morning, it is Tea with Gary Vee
on this Apirl, 30th in two
thousand and 20, right?
Tomorrow is the first day of May
and so, this is the last day of April
and so, let's get right into the show.
- What is up, Gary?
How are you doing?
- I am well Spencer, how are you?
- I'm doing well, dude.
It feels great to be here, man.
It feels great to finally get to help you
although it's not face to face,
we are social distancing
meeting right now.
I wish I was in New York
havin' this talk with you.
Man, it feels great to be here.
I'm gonna get into it, give
a little bit of context
to everyone that's listening right now.
I am a beat boxer, so I
make music out of my face
and yeah, I'm living my
dreams in Hollywood right now.
I have followed your advice
for the past four years,
so this is really really crazy
that we're here right now.
- Thank you Spencer.
Congrats on all your success.
- Thank you, dude thank you
so much for sending me that DM
the other day and saying
congrats on everything
that's happening with me.
It really really means a lot to me,
especially coming from you.
I was homeless last year, my guy.
I was homeless last year
and I was figuring a way
to piece things together, I was
looking myself in the mirror
and I'm like, "hey, look, if
you really really want this,
you wanna be the guy for this,
you gotta put in the work."
And I watched you religiously, I did.
I watched you religiously
and I was fighting adversity
and I got early onto Tik Tok,
really really early onto Tik
Tok and I just played the game.
I put a beat out every
single day and my song.
Those were my mix tapes and
I put it out every single day
and I'm like, "in the
365 if this doesn't work,
shit man, maybe something
else is happening."
But right now I'm sitting at
the top ten within the platform
which is insane cause I went
from not really having a home
and being in a windowless
room to having an audience,
having attention, having people around me
that really really care about me.
I'm getting ad deals, I'm
talking to agencies right now,
I'm looking to release
a song within the next,
little bit more than a month,
but we're planning it out right now.
It's really really exciting,
so my question is for people
that are in my position.
You talk a lot about getting
to this certain place,
finding your group of people,
finding your audience,
and right now people are
gravitating towards me
in order to build a bigger vision,
something more sustainable,
which I really wanna do.
I wanna bring back to
everyone that's given to me,
so yeah, in hopes of forming a team,
I notice that's what you
have built so strongly.
Who are people in a modern
and perhaps future business,
who are some key players, who are people
that you can't live without?
- You know I think, couple things:
one, in the same way that
you kind of took a step back
and said, "let me be
patient but thoughtful"
and you took advantage of the
new attention on a platform,
and it's put you on this path,
I think the first person
you should start with
is a right hand person.
Just an admin, assistant,
just a confidant,
somebody you can trust.
That would be my starting point,
and then really start building around you.
The people I can't live
without might be different than
who you can't live without, meaning,
for example, I despise logistics,
I need an admin to make
sure I know where I'm going
or things of that nature so,
I think you're gonna need
to figure out what you need.
Some people need a PR person
around them to get attention.
I did not.
Some people need a sales
person around them, I do not.
So, you really need to think
about who you need around you
for you, less about me, it's
about you being self-aware,
but I think, given your
circumstance, especially going
from homeless to this,
the extremes of one year,
what I wanna do is make sure
you really gather your thoughts
over the last four years of
the stuff you've heard from me
which is: look for a kind,
good person that can really
bring you value and
compliments the things that you
don't want to be doing.
- I 100% agree with what you're saying,
like you say, double
down on your strengths
and for the weaknesses build on them,
but know that other
people can do them better
and have them help you, so, right now
that's a really really big thing,
I have a very small--
- Just, you need to slow it
down even more than you think.
Right now, even though
it seems like the time,
you need to slow it down in your mind
and press hard in your actions.
So, you need to be making
more content right now,
you need to do...
When I DM'd you, I'm
trying to remember now,
how big is your audience on Instagram?
- Instagram is not
nearly as big as Tik Tok.
- Yeah, I remember, how much?
- So, it's at like, 750K, a
little bit above that right now.
- I would probably, if I were you--
Yeah, I know.
If I were you, I would
probly make a single piece
of Tik Tok content a day
that was moving the audience
to YouTube and Instagram and Twitter.
I would do that every day, once a day.
- Wow, okay. -Like, today's like
a Twitter reply day, everyone.
Like, boom boom boom
you do your beat boxing,
you're like, "yo, first 500
people that reply on Twitter,
I'm gonna reply to."
- Boom, give back.
I like that.
- They get pumped, cause
your audience loves you,
you got 40 million in that youth world,
but now you're building...
I want you to diversify out of Tik Tok,
so I want your actions
to be more hardcore,
but in your brain, I don't
want you buying things,
I don't want you over-hiring things,
you know, I don't want you to think like,
your agent, whoever your
manager's gonna be is gonna
completely...you know,
you need to be smart.
- I've listened to you so far,
I haven't monetized my audience at all.
We're thinking about coming out with merch
in the next month when
we're releasing the song.
- Which could work, which could work.
There's a million ways to do it, but like,
punchline being, slow it down.
- Yes, be more thoughtful,
be more focused, stay hungry,
be grateful, thank you. -
All right, it's been sick,
talk to you soon. - My
god, thank you, bless.
- You got it brother, take care.
Great kid, he's doin' a really
good job, crushing Tik Tok.
- Hi Gary, how are ya?
- I'm well Chris, how are you?
- Good, I'll just get right into it.
So, a little bit of background context,
at 15 I bought my...
I'm a Chicago land DJ,
at 15 I bought my own mixer,
I took all the money in my bank account,
I spent it on one mixer
for six months straight,
I locked myself in a
room and six hours a day,
I just taught myself how to mix
and I did that for six months
before I went on a Carnival cruise
and I met the onboard DJ
there and he actually saw
what I taught myself, then he actually,
him and I exchanged contact info.
He is now my mentor and I
have a internship set up
in the future after I
graduate high school,
and so, after I came back
I joined a family business
for DJing and I have an Instagram
and every single week I force
myself to release a new mix
every Monday and I release two
other posts during the week.
- Okay. - So, I'm active on it.
- Ish.
- Active-ish, yeah.
- Ish, three posts a week
I think is quite low.
- Okay, I only have 65 followers on there.
- So?
- I guess I just don't wanna flood
how many posts are coming out.
- You're definitely not flooding them.
- So, I just wanted to
know, what more can I do,
how do I expand my
growth, how do I like...
- By posting more.
- Yeah, like, how am I gonna...
I don't know, how am I
gonna get more followers?
How am I gonna, I guess get a following
and get to where I wanna be?
- People get very
confused and get tactical
instead of looking at things in the macro.
How did Martin Luther
King get more influence
and get a movement by him?
He spoke in more churches.
- Okay, so, I mean--
- How did Michael Jackson
and Prince and Madonna
become the dominating
music forces of the 80s?
Their fuckin' videos played 24/7 on MTV.
Brother, I'd rather you have the 60...
You're playing defense, you're like,
"oh, I'm gonna flood the
65 and it's gonna go to 42"
without realizing if you
post three times a day
that 65's gonna go to 650.
- Okay.
- Everybody worries about
what's gonna go wrong,
instead of focusing on
what's gonna go right.
You're in a defensive mindset.
- So, okay, I haven't gone to Tik Tok
for Djing, just because I--
- Real quick, I apologize,
cause Claude Diamond
in the comments brings up the question
that people struggle with when I say this,
is it quality or quantity?
Quality is subjective.
Whether I like your fuckin' beats or not,
is my subjective call.
There's people that think
some of the greatest artists
of all time are over rated or under rated,
you know what I mean, that's...
Quality is subjective.
- Mhmm.
- Quantity is not, it's fuckin' math.
- Okay, so essentially,
the more that I put out,
the higher chance of people seeing it?
- Just think about that sentence
and just break it down with me.
It's funny because I get it.
I actually have a lot of empathy
of where your mindset is.
It's where most people are.
Of course, by nature
of what you just said.
Three posts a day on Instagram,
three posts a day on Tik
Tok, 12, 15 posts on Twitter,
one YouTube video a day,
yes, that's exactly right.
I can't control your
quality, I can't control
if you're Timberland or if you're not.
I can't control that, but
I can tell you right now,
the more somebody posts, the
more they're forced to create
and ideate, the more it expands
their ability to be creative
and it gives them more opportunities
to get awareness and opportunity.
99% of people that are out
there and 98% of people
that follow me, go the other way.
Hide behind perfection or other facades
to not put out more,
because of insecurities,
or laziness, or lack of
drive, or lack of conviction
or many other variables, thus giving them
almost no chance of success.
- So, if I were to migrate to Tik Tok,
which honestly--
- It's not migrating, it's adding.
- Okay, so--
- I want you talking everywhere.
Just cause Martin Luther King gave a talk
in a small church in Memphis,
didn't mean he couldn't go
then give a big talk in a big hall in D.C.
- Mhmm.
- The answer is always more.
- And so--
- You're trying to amass
attention, to give you
opportunity to do something you love.
So, by even common sense,
that needs more reps.
- So, you know, I was thinking,
what do I post on Tik Tok,
do I just follow trends?
Because it's a weird
gray area that I'm in.
- Ready for this?
Both.
Make one trend, make a talking video,
make another... then a third trend comes
and you're like "wait a
minute, I can creatively
mix that in to what I do well."
- Mhmm.
- The answer's yes.
- Okay.
- Like, literally this is like a zen...
Like, my concept of
communication is almost zen-like.
It's like, yes, more, yes, yes.
Everyone's asking these
questions and I'm like,
"what the fuck are we
asking these questions for?"
Do you wanna follow a trend?
Yes, do you wanna dance, sure.
I haven't made a dancing
video cause I can't fucking do
the pop-lock shit, but
like if you can, do it.
I made a wine video, I
wanted to make a wine...
I haven't made a wine
video on Musicaly/Tik Tok
for four years, but I
finally feel it's old enough
that I feel comfortable enough
that I made one of those
a couple posts ago, yes.
There's also going to Twitter,
you have a Twitter account or no?
- Yes.
- And searching terms in your industry.
Like, literally Twitter search,
and you search, not generic,
but esoteric terms in your business
you know in mixing culture,
type them in, you see
people talking, jump in
and reply and go into those conversations.
- Okay, but do you think
I'm doing the right thing?
I'm also, not only with
this family business,
but I'm also going to other,
I'm looking up other
party groups in Chicago
and I'm going to them, I'm
saying, "if you need a DJ,
here I am."
- Yes, but that's sales.
That's sales, you're doing
a good job with sales,
you're not doin' a good job with brand.
- Yeah, I guess, that's why
I think I came on here today,
just because I literally
just need to find a way how
to grow that fan base, I
guess, how to grow that number.
- It's tough to grow anything
if you're not watering it
and content is water.
- So, okay, all right on Twitter
then I'll make text posts
saying like, "hey,
here's what's comin' out,
how are you guys doin'?"
- I would talk more
about the overall genre.
Nobody cares yet about
what you've got coming out.
- Okay. -Just like nobody cared
that I was...
Nobody cared my opinion on wine at first
for the first two years,
I just talked about wine.
- Mhmm.
- Got it?
- All right, so I would
more or less talk--
- Less about you, you're a sales...
I like where you're at on sales,
but when you make content,
you have to bring them
value, not make it about you.
You need to make it about it, or them.
- On Twitter then, I would just be like,
you know, the billboard top ten,
look at them and be like,
"hey, look at this music."
- Yes. -This is what's happening
in the community. - Yes, yes.
- And then, I go onto Tik Tok, you know,
duet Charli D'amelio for all I care.
- Yes, that's right, that's right.
You're doin' three a day, so
if you're gonna duet Charli
or if you're gonna just sit there and talk
or if you're gonna follow a trend
and make one of those, yes.
- Okay, so--
- Got it?
- All right, thank you.
- All right, you got it
brother, talk to you soon.
- You too, see ya.
- All right.
Lookin' a little younger this morning,
caught Dustin off guard.
Dustin you didn't see, you know
I had a little fun last night.
Before I fully shaved it off,
I did something pretty good.
- What'd you do?
(Dustin laughs)
- You should've kept that.
(both laughing)
- I was gonna get 'em this
morning but I was like "eh."
- Aw man, you could've kept that
it would've been a great
surprise for everyone watching,
just to see that.
- I was thinkin' about it.
All right, let's keep goin'.
Jeremy, how are you?
- Hey, how's it goin', Gary?
- Lookin' good.
- Dude, this is awesome, truly an honor
and privilege just to get on,
this is really cool.
- Thank you, brother.
- Yeah, so my question revolves around
ad spend on social media.
- Okay.
- I recently published a
book back in mid-January,
is when it went live or for
sale on Amazon and everybody
and this was, book was kind of
my story about my experiences
as a kid being bullied
and what I went through
and then, kind of, evolved into discussing
a little bit about how it
affected me later on in life
and then what my thoughts are
on how to fix the epidemic
which is just growing
and growing every year.
I'm probably two thirds of the
way done with my second book
which is gonna cover some topics about
all of the failures in my life.
Everything from... When I started out
I was gonna write about all the failures
of managers and bosses
that I ever worked for
and kind of point the finger saying,
"here's how this guy screwed up"
and I was gonna say why that was wrong
and here's how they should've acted
and then I realized that
that was ridiculous of me
to try to write something like that
and I actually, after watching
a lot of your content,
I really changed my
whole perspective on that
and said, "All right,
here's everywhere I--"
- Jeremy, on that point,
were you able to see
the attractiveness of accountability?
- Yes. - I'm proud of you, bro.
- Actually, you know what it was,
I wanna say probably, and the
second book was the first one
I started writing, but as I
started to write that book,
I'm like, "wait a minute,
I'm 'bout to explain
how all these things
failed, why have I failed
at so many different things
and that's when I kind of did
a lot of soul searching
and wrote my first book
about my bullying experiences,
but it was, I wanna say
January of last year in 2019,
I think I was at the gym,
runnin' on the treadmill or somethin',
or was out for a run, I don't know,
but I was listening to
one of your keynotes
in my headphones as I'm runnin'
and I wanna say it was
probably a keynote you did
in Singapore or Philippines,
it was overseas I believe
and I don't know what the show
was or the conference was,
but in the middle of it, you're addressing
all these entrepreneurs and
you were making the point
about accountability and you said,
"look, everything that
happens at VaynerX media,
is my fault, 100%"
and I can't remember, I
just literally stopped
what I was doing and I
was like, "Holy shit"
and I really started listening to that
and I was like, "wow"
and it just completely opened
up everything for me and--
- You know what's crazy about it is
I actually genuinely mean it.
- Oh I know you do. - I genuinely,
really believe that and it's empowering.
People love the short term good feeling
of blaming someone else, but it leads
to very very very bad long
term life on the flip side.
It's not fun to say, "this
is fucked up because of me"
but that's like a short
term pain and long term
it's created incredible serenity and peace
and happiness for me, I
feel fully in control.
- Oh, absolutely.
Well, you always used to say
that a lot of your haters say,
"who cares about Gary, he just says
the same thing every time."
Well, I don't think
that's the point to make.
The real point is you're
consistent in your message
and that's what I loved about
it and I took that to heart
and so, the one I'm
writing now is basically,
I'm looking at things that I
failed or dropped the ball on
and instead of pointing
the finger at a boss
who may have dropped the
ball or treated me terribly,
I can at least start to identify,
here's what I should have
did, and here's how I--
- Correct, correct
- Could've won in that situation.
- Including... you know,
you can't control people
and if you have a terrible
boss, maybe you just need
to work somewhere else and
that's you taking control of it.
You know, I love your hoodie
and I love this country, obviously
I was born in the former Soviet Union,
but like, sometimes when people
really get upset with America,
I have a lot of empathy,
because their experience may be difficult,
but I always remind them,
you could move to Sweden, you could.
- Sure.
- You know, it seems extreme,
it's like selling your...
You know I talk, I know, it
sounds like you follow me,
I talk a lot about selling your home
when you can't afford your lifestyle.
When I started talking about
it a year and a half ago,
the entire real estate
community got upset me,
this and that, I was like,
"it's fine, people can be upset with me,
but like, ya could."
You know, to me, I don't care
about how money compounds
or what the value of something is.
If one's unhappy, there
is no smarts behind it.
I don't care that you make
a million dollars a year
in this business, if it
burns you to the ground
in your emotions, it was a bad idea.
You were better off doing this other thing
for 73,000 a year.
It's not super complicated.
Yesterday I was in a big
Australian radio show
and I was talkin' about my optimism
and the DJ was like, "man,
you're a little too optimistic,
what about all the death?"
I'm like, "what about all the people
that's lives have been saved by COVID?"
- Mhmm.
- Does the world realize
that if COVID started
two months earlier, Kobe
Bryant would be alive?
- Yeah.
- Like, you know how many
people die in traffic accidents
every day in America?
Do you know how low
that number is right now
cause nobody's driving?
- Crime rates are down, everything, yeah.
- Yes, there's incredible pain
and there's people who passed
specifically cause of COVID
and they would've lived
for another 50 years
and then on the flip side, there's people
that were going to die because...
And that's where I get into in my mind
which is like, it's just how you sit
and you were seeing it as
like, it was Rick's fault
and Stan's fault and
Jay's fault and then boom,
one fuckin' sentence and
you're like, "wait a minute."
And that accountability leads to control
because when you think it's
everybody else's fault,
you feel so sad cause you're like,
"fuck, they're in control."
People don't understand,
control is the happiness,
control is--
- I hated my last
corporate boss that I had
before I left my job, I hated him
cause he was a true bully
and I didn't know how to deal with him
and what made it worse was the fact
that I looked at this
guy as he's affecting my,
not only just me but, my
family's financial well-being,
he's affecting whether or not, everything,
so my hate for this guy grew more and more
and it's like, I look back on it now,
I'm like, I could've handled
this guy so much better.
I lost a lot of my focus
cause I was just so focused
on the fact that he didn't like me
and it seemed like he wanted
to push me out the door
and a lot of guys on our
team felt that way but--
- And I think what people
don't understand is,
getting pushed out the door,
AKA walking out the door
is a powerful move.
- Yeah.
- You know?
And most people feel like
that guy won, I don't,
because when everybody
walks out there door,
that guys gets fired by what's above him.
- Yeah.
- People are confused.
Every single person here
is actually 100% in charge.
This is a huge moment.
I really appreciate you coming on,
you're getting me going here.
I'm like really going
down a path I want to.
You're actually 100% in
charge, you actually are.
What is required, to get
out of the most difficult
situations, may feel
super uncomfortable, or not
the ideology of how you saw it
but once you change your ideology
and once you stop putting
something on a pedestal,
a dream, a thought, an idea
and instead just living
in the actual moment,
you actually realize,
you're 100% in charge.
You can move, - Yeah.
You can get divorced, you can quit a job,
you can do anything if you've
got humility and confidence.
If you have humility and confidence,
you can do everything.
- Mhmm, I believe that 100%.
I think that's kind of the joy
of bein' a small business owner, too.
Whether it's a pizza
shop or a media company,
or whatever it is you have
that you're the business owner,
it's all on you.
- You know how many
people bought homes, cars,
and went on vacations
in the last two years
that they couldn't afford on paper
and small business owners
that are now blaming COVID?
Like, see the world hates me.
I'm like, no the world doesn't hate you,
you have bad behavior.
The last four years you
could've been saving money
and you could be using
that money right now,
growing your business,
but you took the money
out of the business and
you bought a Porsche.
- 100%.
- I know, I know.
- It's like, the people
right now, I've put out
a couple comments on Facebook
and Twitter here and there
about, all right we're all on quarantine
for the last almost two months
now, what are we all doin'?
I know most people are sleepin' in,
most people are just hangin' out
and that's good to relax a little bit,
but I also said, "what
better time to do something,
try something."
I'm not saying everybody needs to get out
and start runnin' ten
miles, it's is there a hobby
you wanted to get into, is
there books you wanted to read,
things that have been
stacking up in your life
that you haven't been able to do.
Well, hello this is the time.
- There's so much...
Somebody hit me up the other day
and said, "Gary, I feel
useless, I'm not doin' anything,
I wanna get back, I have no money."
I'm like, you could've retweeted
the all in challenge.
Dustin.
Like, you're following me every day,
watching eight hours a day,
I'm talking about this thing.
I'm not even asking you for
the 10 dollar raffle ticket
to go into my thing,
you could just share it
on your Facebook.
99% of the people watching
this every fuckin' morning,
have not even shared allinchallenge.com.
- Right.
- Cause people don't get
that they're in control.
People talk shit, Jeremy.
"oh, I wanna give back, but
I don't have the resources."
Sure you do, you have
14 followers on Twitter,
that's called resources.
You have 113 contacts in your cell phone.
You can literally say,
"have you checked out
this all in challenge?
You should buy a ten
dollar raffle ticket."
Every fuckin' person here could do that
and feed somebody that's
hungry for all the fuckin'
hundreds of emails I'm
getting every day of
"I wish I could be giving back right now."
You can, it's not just
money, it's awareness.
- Yeah. - There's a million...
You know, I don't get it.
- You can go down that list
of all of the challenges
and just find one and
say, "hey, this challenge,
my friend or cousin or whoever--
- Here's one, here's one,
every single person here,
if you can go to the Instagram
profile or the Twitter
of your favorite celebrity
and athlete and say,
"hey, you should join
the all in challenge."
James Harden might see that.
You're in control.
"My vote doesn't count, I don't have..."
Everybody can make anything happen.
- Yeah. - This is an incredible...
It's called the Internet.
(Jeremy laughs)
Accountability is the
greatest drug in the world.
- Absolutely, and I'm hopin'
that that will reign true
when I finish this book in, I don't know,
hopefully another couple
weeks I'll have it done
and I can start editing and get it done.
- And Jeremy, the best way to sell a book
and be successful at that
is to give away free content
about the subject matter,
every day, 24 hours a day.
- So, and it's funny, I'm
glad you brought that up
cause one of the things I did is,
I think maybe six months
ago you started talkin'
about Tik Tok and at the time
I took exactly the attitude
that you said we all would which was,
"all right, that's for teenage kids,
I'm 48, I'm not gonna get on Tik Tok.
There's no way."
But then I remember at one point,
it was probly around
Christmas time you had said,
"hey, just get on it and watch it.
Spend a couple weeks, a
month, two months, whatever,
and just watch and just keep scrollin'."
So I did that and I was like, holy crap.
Aside from all the dance
videos or whatever,
there are a ton of people,
especially older people.
My favorite is all the parents
in their 40s that are on it,
specifically to ruin it for their kids.
- 100%. - I love that.
- 100%.
- So yeah, and I think probly
last week I just started...
You know, I'd go out for
a run and I'd get done
and I'd have a thought in
my head about something,
I'd just put the camera
on and just roll with it
and then throw it up on
Tik Tok just to do it
and I was very hesitant at first
cause it's a self esteem thing, you know,
I'm putting myself out
there, the exposure is
what scares the crap out of
me and I'm sure everyone else,
so but I just did it
and I started doin' it
and I think that this
is an excellent platform
where I can...
60 seconds, don't have to worry about it.
I have FinalCut Pro and I
edit stuff and I'm like,
I don't even need to do
that, just throw it on there,
forget about everything else.
- Make it.
I'm proud of you Jeremy, I
like where you're headed.
Keep goin'.
- Hey, so...
- Please.
The last thing was,
regarding my question was on ad spend.
So, when my first book came
out I did a bunch of ads
on Facebook, Twitter, Instagram
and I'm tryin' to figure out
LinkdIn and get that right.
What I noticed though, and
after talking to my publisher,
is that there's a 90 day
lag between the purchase
and sales data coming out.
So, somebody bought the book
today, it'd be three months
before I'd know that sale occurred.
- The Amazon rank moves by the second.
- What's that? - Your publisher's
thinking old school.
You can see the Amazon
rank change by the second.
- Oh, I didn't know.
I gotta make a note of that.
- Yeah, if you look at your Amazon rank
on your book rankings,
you can get an indicator,
it updates every hour on
how your ad spend's doing.
- Okay.
- That's your answer.
- That I didn't know,
that'll be good to know.
I did notice that when it
first got put on Amazon
in January there was, they
had one copy in stock,
which the publisher told
me that's how it's gonna be
until it starts to sell.
Now, I think they're up
to 11 or 12 in stock,
which, that's somethin'.
- Better than zero.
- Absolutely.
- Run the ads, run content towards it,
link all your social media
accounts to the amazon URL.
All your default links
in all your profiles.
Make 10-15 pieces of content a day
and look at the Amazon rank every hour.
There's your tactic.
- I love you man.
- I love you back, see ya.
- Thank you.
- You know, it's funny.
Couple things there to recap that call.
One, as you saw in the last
18 seconds of that call.
I can go tactics all day long.
I spend 99% of my time on macro,
because fixing the sink is not interesting
if you don't have the well fixed, right?
You can Google what I just said to him
as like, "how do you see if your ad spend
is doing well on Amazon?"
It's the same thing with the
people that are mad at me
in the comments right
now for interrupting.
It's my style, I get what he's saying
and I'm trying to move to the point
and I'm trying to bring
value to everybody.
I understand what he's saying.
The reason all the callers are so happy
is they know that I understand
what they're saying.
I understand that it might
not be the best style,
it might not be the kindest,
or it might come off like I'm a douche
or only wanna hear myself speak.
I understand everything you're saying.
I promise you, 100% of the fuckin' energy
and focus is on value.
We have an hour, I'm tryin' to get through
and get as much as possible.
The caller might not be upset.
You might've not processed it, but I have.
You're also more than
welcome to do your own show.
Plus, there's unlimited
content of podcasters
and interviewers who let people
finish their entire thoughts.
You can watch that unlimited.
Everyone's got their own
style and the value comes
if you really look second layer.
Let's keep it goin'.
- Hey, Mackenzie. - Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
- I'm nervous but, I'm good. -Don't be.
- I'm really happy to be here.
- I'm happy to be with you.
- And I'm thanking you
so much for doing this,
I just appreciate it so much,
just saw your videos like three years ago
and watch them almost every day, so...
- Thank you. - Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- So, just to kind of start off,
I'm from Portland, Oregon,
near Chris actually.
- Nice. - I'm only an hour from him.
And I'm 21, basically I
work at a job that is okay
but I don't wanna do it forever,
so recently I decided to launch...
Well, working on launching
a meal prep business
and I love Latin culture.
It gets me really fired up.
I always try and learn Spanish,
been trying to learn for a while.
My boyfriend is Mexican-American,
but, something I really enjoy.
So, we decided to start
a Mexican inspired meal-prep company.
- Okay.
- So, the meals are healthy,
so it's kinda geared towards people
that have trouble losing weight,
because they don't wanna eat
dry chicken breast and broccoli.
So, basically, I'm having
trouble with social media
because one, I'm not a trainer,
and two, I'm not a nutritionist.
So, I need to know how do I provide value
without stepping out of my lane?
- Opinions and information that you know.
You know, when I got
huge in the wine world,
everyone's like, "oh,
are you a sommelier?"
I'm like, no I worked in a wine store
and didn't have to work in a
restaurant and get a sommelier
certificate, I learned in the streets.
Don't put trainers and
nutritionists on a pedestal.
Yes, those professions',
certifications can give them
potential surface level clout
to be able to talk about it.
The reason you can talk about it is
because you're Mackenzie
and you're a human
and you have an opinion on
what fucking corn and salsa
and fuckin' beef and
chicken and fuckin'...
You have an opinion, that's why.
Don't underestimate your opinion,
you don't need to be an expert.
- Okay. - I promise you
right now, I don't have
a psychology degree,
I'm willing to go up against
people that have them
cause I have natural talent.
- Right.
- I didn't go to business
school, do you understand?
- Yeah.
- You know, you're at a young age
where the structure puts
certificates and process
on a pedestal, people put
process or checking the box
on a pedestal versus real life.
You have passion for Latin culture,
that's already giving you permission.
- Right. - You genuinely like it.
- Yeah.
Okay... - You're having trouble
on social media because
you have the insecurity
of not thinking you're the part
which then stops you from making.
- 100%.
- I know.
(Gary laughs)
- And then--
- So, real quick, not to
get to the second part,
so let's put a nail in this coffin.
You have permission, I'm giving it to you.
Here's your certificate,
it's a fucking Gary Vee certificate.
You can fuckin' post your fuckin'
opinions about Latin food.
- Okay.
So, that was kind of like,
obviously I have an insecurity,
but that was the excuse on what to make
and then, should I just like,
I don't even know, like
just posting like...
Cause I don't wanna be...
There's a lot of companies
in my area and all they do is
post, post, put your orders
in, put your orders in,
they're not really providing value.
So, should I just kind of post,
I don't know if I wanna do--
- Have you ever read
Jab Jab Jab, Right Hook?
- No.
- Okay, give Dustin... - I've heard of it.
- Okay, give Dustin your
address, once you come off here
he'll grab you, we'll get your address
and I'm gonna send you a copy.
- Okay, thank you.
- But to help everybody
who's not gonna get a copy,
give value, give value, give
that value, ask for business.
Jab, jab, jab, right hook.
Talk about you, talk about
you and your boyfriend,
talk about your favorite things,
show a nice picture, make a funny video,
and then ask, but I'm
telling you right now,
Tik Tok, I'm telling
you right now, Tik Tok.
- Okay thank you.
- You're welcome, Mackenzie, take care.
- Bye.
- Yup, it's an interesting show.
The lack of beard is giving me
some interesting energy here,
Dustin, I'm feelin' kind of sharp.
(Dustin laughs)
What are you laughin' about?
- Just the lack of beard.
- Good, keep it movin'.
- Tanner, what's good?
Can't hear you.
All right, Tanner?
See what's goin' on on my Tik Tok.
People what's good, Tarren you good?
Yup, go to the next one, thank you.
Stan what's good, Ryan
Harmen, what's good?
Freestyle's Nick Waller, what's good?
Good morning Derick,
Brad, Jennifer Dalkin,
appreciate you this
morning, John Hollywood.
Hi.
_ Holy shit, can you hear me?
- I can, what's your name?
- Rhi.
- Rhi, nice to see you. - It's Mariah
but I go by...
- Yeah.
- Would I be able to shameless plug first?
- Sure.
- So, if I could, could I have
a follow back on Instagram?
- Mhmm.
- It's at... I have like
a stage name type thing,
it's @lettielotoj, it's
L-E-T-T-I-E-L-O-T-O-J.
I know that sounds like a porn star name,
but it's like a mixture
of my parents names, so...
And I'm doing this thing... - I got you.
- Thank you!
- You're welcome. - Oh my gosh.
My life just was made,
I'm doing this thing
that I wanted to ask you to donate to
and kind of put it out there
to the fans that are your fans,
I don't know why I'm not
talking like a human being.
So, I'm gonna go out in the community
and help the homeless,
the female population
with items for their menstrual cycles,
so me and my mom lived in my car last year
and I've been homeless at
other points in my early life
and it fucking sucked to be on your period
and not have a change of clothes
and not have a shower and it's
embarrassing and humiliating
when you mess up your
clothes, so I was like,
well that felt like shit, so I'm gonna...
I put some money aside, cause right now
I have my stimulus check and that's
really all me and my mom
have, but I was like,
well I wanna give back to
the people that donate,
so I decided that I'm gonna
give 'em a 10 dollar gift card
to whatever their store
or restaurant of choice is
as an incentive to donate,
but I'm taking tampons,
preferably variety packs
so it can help people
with different needs and situations
and then pads, cleansing
wipes or baby wipes
and then over the counter pain medicine,
so Midol or Tylenol and
you can just DM for that
and I'll give you the
address to send items.
- Yeah, I'm gonna send you
a DM right now with my...
Actually I'll just email it to you.
Oh, I see you've hit me up
a bunch on DM, thank you.
- Yes, oh my god.
- I just DM'd you my email.
I'm an early investor in a tampon company,
direct to consumer and
I'm gonna hit them up,
I'm gonna see where they're at,
I might be able to help you
so, send me an email, okay?
- I don't know how many ten
dollar gift cards I can afford.
That would be great. - Not many,
and so I'd like you to keep it
and actually use it as a base
for you to...
Tough to be selfless
without first being selfish.
I'd rather you use that stimulus check
to actually create the base
of a stability situation
for you and I will come in
and help you with what you're
trying to do from a good
place because I can,
so we'll do that instead.
You keep your check and start figuring out
how to build a world that
doesn't out you back into a car,
I'll come in and help you
and we'll get some pads and tampons
to the people that need it.
- That's so sick dude, thank you
and I'm sorry I look like an
entire grown ass man right now.
- You don't, you look like
an amazingly beautiful woman
with a very nice heart.
Dust, let's drop her Instagram,
I have a funny feeling
that we can get a lot of
people to help out here.
It's L-E-T-T-I-E-L-O-T-O-J,
L-E-T-T-I-E-L-O-T-O-J.
- Slower please.
- Get faster bro, come on, fuck you.
- L-E-T-T-I-E-L-O-T-O-J,
here you go Dustin.
L-E-T-T-I-E.
- Yeah, I got you, I got you.
VaynerX nation, let's step
up, hit us this lovely lady.
DM her. - And I just wanted
to thank, I'm sorry I cut you off,
I just wanted to thank you
for recognizing my question.
Cause I tried, as you can
see in DM, like several times
so the fact that you
have millions of options
and you picked me is like huge.
I've been watching you for six years
and I've wanted this from day one, so...
- Well, we're here.
- This is sick as fuck.
- Agreed.
I'll be in touch.
- For sure. - Send me an email right now.
- Okay, can I ask my question?
- Yes of course, I apologize.
Go ahead. - No, no you're fine.
I was like oh my god.
So, I make content basically
documenting my daily life,
I've struggled with
depression since I was 16
and that's the main reason
I started the channel.
So I basically was like,
well there have been times
where I've wanted to harm myself
or had really dark thoughts
and just the thought
of somebody else, primarily kids,
I was hearing a lot about people
that were like 15, 16 struggling with this
when they should be worried
about getting their braces off
and passing driver's ed, they're
like, "do I wanna be here?"
And I'm like, that's
fucked up so, I was like,
well it felt like shit so I'm gonna...
It was really nerve-wrecking
to be that transparent,
you know, because there's such a stigma
surrounding mental
health, but I documented
if I had an episode, I
took my meds on camera,
cause I was like, "I didn't
turn into a fuckin' dragon."
Like, there's so much stigma
around even medication
and I documented, like, I
had a run with addiction
and stuff like that
for the month of April,
I document my experiences
with sexual assault.
Basically, my question is
like, I'm worried that,
you know, cause I wanna
do this for a living
and that means that I
have to have at least
a certain amount of income and I'm nervous
that when people of influence see my page,
they're gonna see me as a
liability because sometimes
I think I'm being too transparent.
- You're goin' too general.
That makes sense to me,
you're right, 80% will
and the 20% that you need to
be connected with anyway won't.
See, people always don't act themselves
cause they're worried
about some other force,
college, a boss,
- Right. - a professional industry
accepting them.
What they don't realize
is, then that means
they wanna be accepted
by an establishment,
by being them "fake" selves.
- Mhmm.
- Rhi, do you know how many people,
literally the entire
speaking industry in 2009,
every speaking agent, every agency,
every conference literally
communicated to me via
email, phone call, face to
face, "you have so much talent
to be a big speaker.
You will never be a big speaker
because you curse too much.
Don't curse and you can
be a great speaker."
- Yeah, I heard that shit too.
- Look at these people,
look at these people,
look at these people.
You know what's happened
over the last ten years
between me and those ten people?
I fuckin' lapped them,
I fuckin' lapped them.
- For sure, yeah.
- You know why?
Because I didn't waver.
I didn't wanna be accepted
by an establishment
that I didn't respect anyway.
Why the fuck do you wanna pander to people
that you don't respect anyway?
- Oh my god, and like, the other thing
that I realized is, I
was off for five months,
they got me for five months
because my family was like, you know,
"law enforcement looks at
that, potential employers"
and I was consequently having
a hard time finding a job--
- Right listen to me, judge the judgers.
- Okay.
- Pay attention to who's
giving you that advice.
- Yeah, I mean they're
working nine to fives
and I wanna be a public speaker.
You know, like Kobe
didn't want Shaq's stats.
Like, if you don't want their
numbers or their lifestyle
then don't take their--
- The only thing that you
need to layer with that
is figuring out what
you need to do mentally
and operationally and practically,
and not putting yourself
back in a vulnerable spot
of being in a car, right?
Like, for example, you're a sweetheart,
but I can't have you
taking your stimulus check
and spending it on giving
when you don't have.
I'm being serious here.
- Yeah, I'm horrible
with money, but no I'm, yeah--
- You're fuckin' super
horrible with money.
- Yeah, like, the worst.
- Goes back to what I said earlier,
like, you could share the all in challenge
and keep the money and
start building to stability.
- Yeah, well... - Your relationship
with money is garbage.
- The reason I wanted
to do that was because, one
of my tactics for helping
to combat my depression was
getting the focus off of myself.
- I respect that. - And I always
journal about it but I wanted
to do something tangible.
- I respect that, but you
need to figure out a different
relationship that doesn't require the fact
that it puts you in a
vulnerable spot, because
once you go back to that vulnerable spot,
you're back to fucking...
you know what happens.
- Yeah, right.
For sure.
- I don't have to tell you,
you know exactly what's
gonna fuckin' happen when you go back
into a fucking car in October.
You're fuckin' off, it's
very hard to do shit
if your legs aren't underneath you.
- Mhmm.
- You're not helpin' anybody.
- Right.
- I need you to get practical about that.
- For sure, I will definitely.
One last thing, I'm sorry,
I'm not tryin' to be selfish,
this is just like,
I don't know if I'll
get this chance again.
I don't mean to put you on the spot
but I was really wanting to ask for a job.
- Okay.
- Because like, the stimulus
money is all we have right now
and my mom bent over
backwards my entire childhood,
she was a single mom--
- So, I'll explain this.
Rhi if you can make content,
then I can give you a shot
and if you can't, I
don't wanna bullshit you,
I'm like, going through a
process of letting jobs go
and I don't wanna sit
here and bullshit you,
but if you are able to
design or video edit,
then you can absolutely take that email
and show me what you can
do and then I can put you
in touch with my team.
- Yeah, and after COVID
man, I'll do it for free.
Like, I'll walk to New York
and sleep in a fuckin' tree,
like, I've slept in a car, so like....
- Send me the emails, we'll talk, okay?
- For sure, thank you so much.
- You're welcome, you're welcome, Rhi.
Let's keep it goin'.
Tanner, fuck.
And this was meant to be such a good talk,
you've got the epic rug behind you,
I got the fuckin' classic curtains,
this was gonna be fuckin'
dynamite, can you hear me?
Sorry Dust, let's keep it movin'.
Let's see what else,
Crystal, thank you so much
for being in here.
Tad, Blard, what's good?
Jenny R., love you back.
Carolynn, what's good?
Pat.
- Gary, can you hear me?
- I can hear you and I can see
an incredible nerd center behind
you, I'm fuckin' impressed.
- Dude, it is, it's a
passion project of mine.
- That's awesome.
- You kinda like kicked my ass
and I'm startin' a YouTube
channel on superheros, so...
- And Tik Tok bro, Tik Tok.
- Dude, I uploaded my first Tik Tok
and got like 600,000 views.
It's insane.
Yeah, no and I kept uploading.
Yeah, and I'm trying
to get three a day in,
but here's, quick question on that.
Does it have to be superhero related,
or can I get my...okay.
- No, dude, people ask me questions...
You know how I always
say, "watch what I do,
not what I say"?
Sometimes it's business,
sometimes it's garage sales,
sometimes it's a Jets photo,
sometimes it's a throwback
to when I was a kid, my
report card, a key note,
- Sure. - some kid
in the fuckin' street, a
cartoon, like, the answer's yes.
- Yeah of course. - Always yes.
- I know it is and it's so
weird I thought about so many
questions to ask and I'm like,
"oh, he answered that all ready,
oh he answered that all ready."
It's awesome, thank you, first of all.
- The question becomes, this
is what this is all about,
the question becomes, you all know that,
I've been so consistent, I'm
been so historically correct,
I'm taking myself out of the question.
I've been right so long about things
that are proven in history,
at this point you know
the tactics are right.
The reason you're not doing it is this,
which is why I switched, four years ago
I started talking more about this.
- Sure. - There's always gonna
be tactics, but then when
people aren't doing it,
when they know the
fuckin' answer, I'm like,
wait a minute, oh right.
Self confidence, self doubt, parenting.
Like, that's what evolved to me
cause I don't understand
why you fuckers aren't...
How the fuck are you
watching this right now
and not posting three
times a day on Tik Tok?
And you know what's crazy?
Out of 10,000 people, 99% are not, pat.
- Yeah.
- 99%.
- Dude, I love it man, you're so fired up
and you make me fired up and
I'm sure the rest of my town
is sick of hearing me talk about Gary Vee.
(both laugh)
- You're fuckin' up the town?
- Right, yeah, so that's
ultimately my goal
and even before I
started listening to you,
that was it, like, I
wanted to be the Gary Vee
of Peoria, where I'm from,
Peoria, Illinois, and so, I'm 27,
I used my skills as a
videographer to build a company
and I'm freelance, I've been
doin' it for about nine years
and so, I guess my question would be:
I know that's gonna make me
great money, I love doin' it,
it's a great career and now
I wanna dabble in some other
things cause my
entrepreneurial spirit, right,
and do I grind at the video
for like three more years
before dabbling, I know
I can dabble, but like,
should I double down before
I invest in other stuff?
For instance, right now--
- Both, the answer's always yes.
You can double down on video and dabble.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Pat, I wanna know your 24 hours
and I wanna know your 7 days a week.
- Thank you. - I wanna know it.
I wanna literally sit on
your shoulder and be like,
"bro you just watched an hour and a half
of fuckin' random videos."
That could have been double down time.
- Before I listened to you, I was watching
four hours of Netflix a day kind of shit.
So, I was like, dude I had time, so okay,
I guess...cause I really
wanna gain value from this
and I know everyone watching,
that's why you do this.
So, right now with the
scenario that's going on, yes,
a lot of people ask me to do sweat equity
and I'm cool with that
if I can get a percentage
of the business, right?
Have you dealt with that a lot?
- Course. - Is that...
- All the time. - How do I--
- You say yes or no.
- Okay.
- Had a guy yesterday who offered me,
these are now big companies,
who say "hey, our cash flow's
fucked up, we want
VaynerX to do this work,
but we'll share the
profits on the back end."
And I said no, that's how I dealt with it.
- Gotcha.
- And then somebody else came in, said,
"hey, we know this is
normally three million,
would you do it for 1.9",
I was like, there's something there,
I'm like, "yes."
- Yeah, sure.
So, should there always be
something a little upfront
before I put in all my...
- I do unlimited stuff for free.
- Yeah and I believe it. - Pat,
this is free.
- Yeah I know, dude this is so sick, man.
I've been doin' this in my town,
I just get people that I
see that have the drive
and I FaceTime 'em and just
start kicking their ass
with these things about like,
documents that I create.
- Listen to me, the answer
is you're 100% in control.
Everybody thinks they're getting gotten.
- Yeah, yeah yeah, that's true.
- You see, like, "oh fuck, this guy's
a better business man than me.
He's tricking me.
He's taking advantage of
me during this down time."
No he's not, he's negotiating.
When you say no and walk away,
he then finds another video person,
or if he desperately wants
you, you're in control.
This is a perfect end to the start.
- Yeah.
- How do you handle it?
You're in control.
It's called negotiating,
it's called business.
- Okay.
- Everyone is trying to...
So many people are not
cut out for business,
or haven't calibrated a business yet.
"Gary, they're fuckin' tryin' to get me."
No they're not, you don't have to say yes.
- Okay, yeah that makes sense.
- No, but really, Pat,
it's so fuckin'...right?
Like, you're not getting hosed,
you're making a decision.
- Yeah, yeah, and I feel like--
- It's not superhero shit,
they're not like some evil
villain that transformed your brain
and you're like, "yes, megatron, sorry."
You're in fuckin' control.
- Yeah, dude that's so
true man, it's so true.
- The problem is, a lot of
people who's time and efforts
are not that valuable, want it to be.
They're actually the wrong party.
They're using ego, they
want the other person
to succumb to them, when that other per-
people are like "Gary, you need to--"
I'm like, I don't need to do shit,
I've got 40,000 videographers
lined up in my fucking DM
right now willing to work
for free for four years
so that they can be
like Batman and D Rock.
Look what's happened to Dustin.
Dustin literally,
literally riding BMX bikes
and all the sudden can
produce any fuckin' podcast
or video show in the world.
- That's what's up, yeah.
For sure.
- I know what my value is,
and other people do as well,
maybe that...you know how many
people passed on free work
because they know their
worth, yet that was the video
that was gonna change their entire career?
The fuckin' audacity when
nobody gives a fuck about you
is insane to me.
People are fuckin' walkin'
around like a Pablo Picasso
and fuckin' Steven Spielberg,
when there's fuckin' 80,000 of them.
All you fuckers grew up
with fuckin' FinalCut
and fuckin' iMovie and YouTube,
you're fuckin' commoditized.
- Yeah, dude, Gary, I'm gonna
watch this a thousand times
and just like relive it,
but the one thing I will say
like, when I'm showing people your stuff,
I always start with the Hot Ones episode,
because that was the first thing I saw,
and it was like... - Is that true?
- It was the first thing I saw--
- Let's break it down,
first time you see it
and you're like, go
through the whole thing--
- Who's this guy?
Everyone looked at me on the couch like,
"you don't know this
guy, like we feel like
this is your life."
And I'm like, "no, I've
never heard of this guy."
So, it was a perfect mixture of comedy
and not so...cause I have some friends
that re like, "oh, I don't listen to Gary,
he told some high schooler to drop out."
I'm like, you saw one clip out of context.
You know what I mean?
So, like, I will go...
I've shared that Hot Ones
probly like ten times,
I've shown my parents, showed...
You know cause my parents are hustlers.
I'm like, "mom, you're 65."
She's killing garage sales her whole life,
they started car shows
when they were younger.
Like it's just insane man.
- Brother, I really
appreciate havin' you on.
- Thank you, man. - You have
such a good spirit.
Like I wanna be your friend.
Like I think you're gonna get
DMs with your handle here,
it's Pat Clark, I think you're
literally gonna get like,
"hey, let's be friends."
- Dude, that'd be awesome man.
Hey--
- And by the way, on the final point,
all the shit in your background,
like bro you need to lean
into putting out content
around superheros on Tik Tok at scale.
- Yeah--
- I'm telling you...
I'm sorry, you do what?
- I do cosplay, so I
dress up and do unboxing
and comment and talk shows.
- I get it, I know that whole scene bro,
I'm telling you, if
you go hard at Tik Tok,
hard at three posts a day,
just feeling your
kindness, youthful energy,
I'm telling you, you're gonna
find yourself at Comic Con
in a way that you could've never dreamed
and you're gonna DM me and be like,
"Gary Vee, I loved you first and now
I fuckin' really fuckin' love."
- I can't wait for that moment, man.
Hey, quick, I don't read
books, but I am jabbin'
here left and right, so
I wanna be a public speaker and stuff.
Any way, you know with events
and stuff being canceled for a while,
do you see online speaking
becoming a big thing
and like, I would love to
apply for VaynerX speakers
or something like that.
- VaynerX speakers you have no shot,
I'll tell you why, cause Steve
and Zach who make the
decisions, they're impossible.
I'm recommending people that
have huge speaking careers,
they're like, "not right."
So like, I'm scared on
the VaynerX speakers crew.
- It's cool, no big man. - But, you should
do what I did.
You should speak for free for a long time
until you don't.
- Yeah, you know I was goin'
to school and volunteering
but not documenting any of it,
so like, dude, literally
you've changed my world.
So, I appreciate it, let's
get someone else on here,
have a good one man.
- Love you man, see you soon.
I appreciate you saying that Josh.
Great show today, I'm glad it's free too.
I really hope everybody enjoyed the show,
like, somebody said the comment,
"no beard, no bullshit."
Today was a very focused fuckin' show,
like we got a lot in
there, Dustin in this hour.
- Yeah.
- Got a good amount in there.
What was your take aways, anything?
- I wrote notes cause things always
are flyin' all over the place for me.
I always like those parts where
it's in between the calls,
like when you're talking
about the whole interrupting
and you wanted to give value to people.
- What's your take on the
interrupting thing, right?
Because you know when you see,
especially cause we've been
doing Coffee and Commerce
and we've been doing Tea with Gary Vee,
people really really get mad at me
and I really understand
cause I think they're right.
I get it, on the other side of it.
I can see the perception
of it and the feeling
but it makes so much sense to me.
Like, point taken, let's
get more value out of it,
I understand on the other
end there's a whole audience
that didn't get the point,
so that's why they want it.
They're not fast enough
or intuitive enough
to actually see it, so
I'm fuckin' that up,
so I'm trying to find my balance, like,
it's really interesting.
Look, I don't think I'm
the greatest interviewer,
I'm not fuckin' Larry King, I get that,
but I like it because I feel like
everybody else does the other
style and you can get that...
There's a trillion fuckin' videos
on YouTube where you can get that.
I don't know, what do you think about it?
- I think it's just...
All ass-kissing aside,
your brain is going faster
than everyone else so it's like,
you already are a step ahead than me,
so you all ready know what
I'm gonna say, so I get it,
that's why you're kind of,
getting to the point all ready.
But...
- It's a fine line, because I
also understand the other side
you know, you have to
do it for your audience,
and if I get it but they don't,
I have to let that breathe,
it's a tricky fuckin' game.
- Yeah, that's very true.
- It's why I don't think
I'll ever be the best
at interviewing, but I also think...
Literally I was reading
comments, somebody was mad at me
yesterday for the Shopify CEO
but then also DM'd me that he
also follows the Shopify CEO
and he got more out of our interview,
thoughts and information
from him than he has
in any of the fuckin' hundred articles
and videos that he's watched
and that makes me lean
into the interrupting.
I don't even call it that,
it's my interview style
that is desperately, desperately
trying to bring value
to the audience.
- Cause, yeah, you understand people,
you know what they want to know
and you're just kind of jumping to it.
- I also know what the interviewer
or the person that's
asking me the question
is actually trying to
get off the interviewee
and I don't want them to,
I want them to get to the real thing.
- Interesting.
- You understand?
I'm putting pressure on the interviewee.
All these incredible guests are just...
Everyone's like "Gary gets
all these incredible guests"
and then fuckin' doesn't let them talk.
I don't want them to
do their press release
that they do everywhere else.
I'm trying to fuckin' help
you and you're fucking
drilling me in the
comments, mother fucker.
(Dustin laughs)
- Yeah--
- Winetext.com today, if you
don't drink brunello, you're
making a huge mistake, one of
the best wines out of Tuscany
in the world.
Today's offer is half price
Thursday, it is finally time
to step up and sign up for
this if you drink wine.
I can't wrap my head around
why you haven't signed up.
Please sign up and then obviously please,
all in challenge, please go
tweet at, leave a comment
in the Instagram comments of
your favorite celebrities.
Please, please, please figure
out how to get more people
aware of the all in challenge.
Allinchallenge.com
Let's get that up.
Let's get a new graphic
starting tomorrow, Dustin,
cause this just says all
in challenge, let's get
the allinchallenge.com part.
I see what you're doin', got
it, you always support it
with the URL below.
- Yeah, I get the other version.
- Yup, yeah let's do that.
Please support the all in
challenge, we're raising,
I think we're at about
25 million, where we at?
All in challenge, we are
at 25 million dollars
raised in two weeks
You mean a lot to me if you supported it
and if you wanna give
a ten dollar donation
to the all in challenge to feed the hungry
during this terrible time,
please check out my auction
on the all in challenge.
Garyvee.com/allinchallenge.
Here's what I'm giving away.
I am giving away the
ultimate Gary Vee experience,
how should that go?
Okay, over the last week
or so, I've been jammin'
with my friend Michael Rubin
and helping out on his all in challenge
that I am accepting right now.
But, allinchallenge.com, please go there.
We are challenging some
of the greatest artists,
entertainers, athletes in the world
to provide a ridiculous
all-time experience
or one of their most iconic
items in their collection
to help raise money to
help feed the hungry
during this ridiculous time
and so now I have to put up my auction.
So my auction, the ulitmate
Gary Vee experience,
here we go, I'm gonna go
off the top of the head,
and you can go on allinchallenge.com
to go bid on this.
I am giving away,
okay, you get to, in the course of a year,
you will go garage sale-ing with me,
and film Trash Talk.
Also you can get a workout
with me and Mike Vacanti
so I know a lot of you pay attention
to that part of my world.
Also, we're gonna go to Wine Library,
and do a $25,000 shopping spree.
That's right, I'm gonna pay my dad,
well I'm gonna donate and
we're gonna pay my dad 25,000
so, $25,000 shopping
spree at Wine Library,
I will walk through the
whole store with you,
tell you the war stories
and you'll buy a bunch
of wine, beer, liquor,
whatever you want, food.
We are going to go to
a Jets game together.
You're gonna tailgate with me,
I never do this, when I
give away Jets tickets,
I never let the person sit with me,
so you will sit with me
during the Jets game.
I won't talk to you during the game,
I'm completely focused,
but you'll get that.
So, the ultimate Jets
experience, tailgate,
full game with me as well.
Also, I'm going to give you
one week play at VaynerMedia
so, this is for you and
a plus one by the way.
So, the two tickets,
we'll do some plus ones,
we'll do some just me and
you depending on what it is.
One full week and VaynerMedia,
getting consulting
and business advice from
team Gary Vee and me
for the entire week.
Hanging out in the pit
where the show's done.
You're gonna be a guest on my podcast,
we're going to do a wine dinner for you
and seven of your friends
at Hunt and Fish Club
in New York City and I'm
gonna fly you all paid,
plus one, to three of my keynotes
and we'll work on those details.
The ultimate Gary Vee experience.
I hope you bid on it, I
hope you get involved,
I hope we raise a lot of money
to help people that need it.
Also what's so fun about the
all in challenge is you get to
challenge people to be in it.
I am gonna challenge all
the VaynerSports athletes,
I expect you in there,
so that's number one,
number two I'm gonna go with...
Ooh you know what?
Timbaland, the super producer
who's completely lighting up
Instagram, Timbaland the super
producer, I'm callin' you out
and finally, I got one, the
Undertaker, one of the great
wrestlers of all time,
please join the challenge.
Everybody go to allinchallenge.com,
please support this, the
experiences ar gonna be nuts.
We've been working,
bleeding out of the eyeballs
for the last week putting
this all together.
You're gonna be blown away
what you're about to see on social media.
Hashtag all in challenge,
please check it out
and please go to your
favorite celebrities, athletes
and entertainers and leave
hashtag all in challenge
to get them involved.
The all in challenge.
Please take it.